mental exercises to learn to control
ones pulse and breathing in really
stressful situations or when very
nervous what do you do mental exercises
so we touched on this very briefly in
the last episode which was on the book
where I talked a little bit about sniper
training visualization is probably your
biggest tool and what in my experience
train train the shit out of it
train train train and when you think
you've trained enough keep training but
when you're not training think about it
think about it the more you think about
it become in tune with yourself okay I'm
gonna get a little Spacey here little
earthy just sit there cuz you know what
you do in your ear sniper you fucking
sit there you have a lot of time to
yourself
you can't really talk cuz you got a job
to do and what you gotta do is you just
gotta okay I know my heart rates go up
here but I do my best to make sure it
doesn't overwhelm my motor functions and
you can control it pretty mint that
pretty easily if you prepare yourself
for that moment but it's all about
preparation training and visualization
even like even making the shot you know
like Tim Kennedy was on here right when
you talk about dry-firing mm-hmm
considered dry firing that this is your
dry firing for for you for controlling
yourself or your brain for your brain
exactly and dry fire your brain like
that and and it only comes from
experience now I guess there's probably
some exceptions to the rule out there
that are just born to be cold-blooded
killers that a second they get behind a
barrel but but for me it was
visualization and just preparing to
accept the feelings that were coming
and also overriding them because that
they could still be happening but you
can still control yourself with the
right kind of preparation and it's also
a perishable skill funny enough I
realized I don't know if that answered
the question but no I think that's I
think that's good and I think for me
one thing that I that I know I do and
this is a I guess it may be considered a
technique but it's like the technique
creates the solution let me explain this
to you one of the things that I do in
stressful situations
there's something that I always try and
do and that is no matter what's going on
I try and remain calm in my voice so
when things are going crazy I try and
get on the radio and say hey we need two
more people over here not hey we need
two more people over here Roger so if
you're gonna talk in a calm controlled
voice then you can't be breathing hard
you can't be excited you can't get angry
you can't get frustrated you have to
lock all that up and get it under
control before you open your lips right
and start saying something and so I'm
always very focused on I am gonna sound
calm cool and collected when I open my
mouth that way and when in in doing that
the only way to make that happen is to
do everything we just talked about
control your breathing
control your pulse control your emotions
get all those things under control and
then say all right we need two more guys
down here immediately now and everybody
goes okay
let's make this happen and coming from
you especially you're the in your kit in
your case you were the boss so if you're
if you're calm cool and collected that
translates to your troopers it
absolutely right so when we wouldn't and
it would for us as well when we were
doing overwatch you know six-two
six-three
you move into your left yeah
no no no no laughs right think about
what happens when you do that so let's
imagine if I let you shoot six there on
your left on your left right I'm
freaking out they would it would all be
it would be lost but your that call your
that voice because we're over with
snipers are overwatch
we're eat what they the troops feel
better when they know okay the snipers
do know overwatch okay we can we're
gonna be okay so if I they're on the
radio and talked the same way so you
know nope okay yeah just fire four
hundred meters north you know fire for a
fact
Roger that you know like you got it
that's a good point I never even thought
of that I think airline pilots train
that too because you know we hit the
turbulence just go ahead and put your
seat yeah yeah actually if you hear
Sully the guy that landed on the river
he's like that yeah yeah we're gonna
have to I think they they have to teach
them that because that's where people
are so apprehensive we've when they're
in the plane favorite part about that is
a it's like yeah we'll be in the river
and the guys like say again we'll be in
the Hudson Roger out and like the plane
it's like real-time you're watching the
video and he's just like yeah yeah we're
in the river we're in the road what in
law by controlling his eyes in order to
control his voice he's got to control
his breathing he's got to control his
temper he's gotta control his emotions
and so that's what I do
in those situations and I'll tell you
what if I haven't if I don't if I'm not
in a situation where I need to talk I'll
just talk to myself be like okay you
know just say that in my head yeah all
right
what is the next movement you're good I
know we're spending a lot of time on the
first question that's but that's what
saved my life Oh
staying if I had gone into shock dude
I'd be dead right and I say it in the
book I say I did my best to go into the
zone so I know I'm bleeding it and I
know this and I know that but in my mind
it was let the system do its job okay
fine Jody it's okay and I just I just
kept saying talking to myself you know
visualizing what okay so that choppers
gonna come in you know and I just
visualized each step and my but the
whole point to it was I couldn't have my
pulse
jackhammer otherwise more Bloods lost
more blood lot and then you're in what
happens right blood gets sucked into
your core when you go into shock and and
that would sucks it out of your brain so
excited of everywhere where you where
you know I I needed to stay conscious so
no anyway a long long answer for one
question but this this is also something
you know you gotta learn practice keep
practicing it you'll figure it out yeah
it always and we talk about this again
all the time on the podcast inoculate
yourself to these stressful situations
that's right Colonel Grossman that's the
guy's name
yes stress inoculation yep inoculate
yourself to the stress so that when you
you get used to it yeah the more stress
will such I mean training going through
training man they they put all kinds of
stresses at you yeah so that you learn
to deal with it and if you want to learn
how to that's your time to practice
controlling all those things absolutely
and I'm not trying to go level seven Zen
Buddha on you all like you need to get
to the mind state to control your
breathing like no it's a practical thing
it's a real thing it's not a yoga thing
it's a practical real thing of hey get
calm down yeah take a deep breath get
yourself under control now it's time to
talk and give clear concise orders then
calm yeah or make that shot or crack one
off if you're in the sniper zone lack a
bad guy